was there any indication of this was
there any indication of any tension
between the government there and the
military forces well there's a very
long-standing history of tension between
Turkey's elected governments and the
army here
I think the Army's traditionally seen it
itself as a kind of secular bastion of
the Turkish state that tried to sort of
rein in the excesses so it it's
perceived them of the democratically
elected governments of the day and this
government the AKP government which you
stab doesn't add on its head before he
moves to become the president two years
ago it came to power and tried very hard
to trim the influence of the army and it
seemed for a long time that they've been
very successful in doing that Yami
certainly its role in public life had
vastly diminished as last year's I think
many people didn't think they had the
capacity to do this anymore
so it's come as a huge shock there's a
bell you mentioned there briefly about a
history of these things happening in
Turkey can you if you would in just a
couple of seconds give us a brief update
a brief historical perspective on why
this seems to continue to happen in
Turkey well it's a very good question at
the moment there seems to be a kind of
information war with you know each side
spitting messages over the airwaves or
the other so it's hard to come to a
concrete understanding of what what's
going on right now and what what exactly
this fits into but certainly there's
been a long history of tension I mean
more recently it's taken the shape that
the Adron government well when he when
he was formerly the head of it the
advanced government was perceived by a
number of citizens as taking a more
authoritarian turn of course they
they've won a series of elections three
nationwide elections very recently so
they certainly have the support of a lot
of the people but there's a section of
society that feels that their rights are
being ignored and those tensions have
certainly been a big feature of tech
concepts in the last year Chinese day
whether this fits into that or otherwise
but thank you
yes Bloomberg's Isabel Finkel joining us
from central Istanbul in Turkey
Isabel thank you again there seems to
have been as Isabel was very careful to
point out some people are taking great
pains not to call this a coup but there
has been some sort of military action in
Turkey we are seeing reports of very
very heavy gunfire heard outside
Turkey's presidential palace